- Good afternoon, everyone.
My name is Sten Vermund.
I'm proud to serve as the dean
of the Yale School of Public Health,
and I'm delighted to welcome you
to the Global Health conversation series,
sponsored by the Yale
Institute for Global Health.
This series is a venue for
our community to learn from
and connect with innovative
leaders in global health.
In addition to YIGH,
we're indebted to the George
Herbert Walker, Jr. lecture
in International Studies
at the Whitney and Betty MacMillan
Center for International
and Area Studies at Yale,
for sponsoring this series,
including today's event.
So it's a pleasure to be with you today
and to introduce our speaker.
Each year since 1988, on
December 2nd yesterday,
we've commemorated World AIDS Day.
I remember vividly the very first one.
I had started my job
at the NIH on that day.
And this highlighted the urgent need
and the inequalities
that drive HIV and AIDS
and other pandemics around the world.
The theme for this year's World AIDS Day,
is end inequalities,
end AIDS, end pandemics.
So 40 years plus, since the
first AIDS cases were reported,
HIV still threatens the world.
Today, the world is off track
from delivering on the shared commitment
to end AIDS by 2030,
not because of a lack of
knowledge or tools to beat AIDS,
but because of structural inequalities
that obstruct proven solutions
to HIV prevention and treatment.
As well as being central to ending AIDS,
tackling inequalities
will advance the human
rights of key populations,
and people who are living with HIV,
make societies better
prepared to beat COVID-19
and other pandemics
and support economic
recovery and stability.
Fulfilling the promise
to tackle inequalities
will save millions of lives,
and will benefit society
in myriad of ways.
To celebrate or
commemorate World AIDS Day,
and discuss some of
these important issues,
we are so pleased to have with us today,
Dr. Angeli Achrekar, the acting
US Global AIDS Coordinator
and special representative
for global health diplomacy
in the Department of State.
Dr. Achrekar has dedicated her career
as a public servant to global HIV AIDS,
women and girls health and
global public health development.
After working in India
and later with UNICEF
headquarters on adolescent health,
she accepted position with US CDC in 2001,
where she focused
on integrated adolescent
health's programs and services.
Since 2003, Dr. Achrekar
has been working on PEPFAR's
global HIV AIDS efforts.
And in 2005, she went to South Africa
to help local governments
plan and implement a rapid
assessment of drug use,
and sexual HIV risk patterns,
among injecting and non-injecting
drug users and sex workers
in three cities Durban,
Pretoria and Cape Town.
After serving as country officer for CDC,
she became the senior
public health manager
supporting cross cutting
system wide sustainability
activities and strategies
in CDC's division of global HIV AIDS.
In 2011, she joined the
US Department of State
and helped lead the conceptualization
and development of saving
mothers giving life,
as well as facilitating
the implementation of
this important program.
For those of you who don't know about it,
it was a public and private partnership
that impacted maternal and neonatal health
in the context of HIV service delivery.
Dr. Achrekar holds a
doctorate in public health,
from a very good program,
the University of North
Carolina Chapel Hill.
We love that program, we
love our friends at UNC,
but most importantly,
she has her Master's of Public Health
from the Yale School of Public Health.
So welcome Dr. Achrekar
back to your alma mater.
- Thank you so much, Dr. Vermund,
and to the entire Yale community,
and the Yale University but
specifically a huge thank you
to the Yale Institute of Global Health.
I'm just so privileged to be here with you
commemorating World AIDS
Day that occurred yesterday.
I have a few slides to cover
and to share the experience,
and to provide an update
on where we are globally,
if that's okay.
So if I could start with the presentation
to really walk you through
commemorating World AIDS Day,
and talking specifically
about the impact that
we've had as a globe,
through the President's
Emergency Plan for AIDS Relief.
On the next slide, please.
I always start every presentation
by talking about how
critical and instrumental
the unwavering bipartisan congressional
and presidential leadership
of PEPFAR has been.
We are 18 years in this
fight through PEPFAR,
which again started with
President George W. Bush in 2003.
Each subsequent president
has picked up the mantle
and really led and supported this program
with an incredible amount of effort.
We've also enjoyed bipartisan
support across 10 congresses
over the nearly two decades
of the program's life.
Most recently with the
current administration,
the Biden Harris administration,
I can't even begin to tell you
how incredible their support has been.
And I'm pleased to be
able to talk with you
in the next couple of slides here,
about how President
Biden really leaned in,
particularly on this recent
World AIDS Day, yesterday,
but really how the administration
has been leaning in
and building upon
the successes of all the
previous administrations since.
So on the next slide.
Yesterday, President Biden
hosted an incredible event
at the White House,
where the domestic and
global HIV community
was brought together,
private sector, universities, Congress,
faith-based organizations, activists,
it was an extraordinary
in the US government,
coalition of people,
of passion that has been
built over the past 40 years
in this fight.
As a part of his remarks,
he announced PEPFAR's
latest global results,
which are nothing short of extraordinary.
He announced that together through PEPFAR,
with countries and communities,
we've saved more than 20 million lives,
we've prevented millions
of HIV infections,
and helped at least 20 countries
bring their HIV epidemics under control.
This is extraordinary, particularly
in the face of COVID-19.
But just full stop,
without a vaccine or cure
to have nearly 19 million people,
women, men and children
on life saving treatment,
for example, is incredible,
to have prevented nearly 28 million,
or to have conducted nearly
28 million circumcisions
in order to prevent HIV infections
among men and young boys.
Again, nothing short of extraordinary.
Next slide, please.
We have over the years,
supported population-based
surveillance studies,
household surveillance studies,
to really validate results
that we're seeing in countries.
Here we're seeing a
somewhat of a busy slide,
but what's important to note,
is how far countries have come
in terms of achieving their 90, 90, 90,
sustainable development goals.
This is tracking the percentage of PLH,
people living with HIV that
are aware of their status
and those that are aware of their status
that are on life saving treatment,
and then those that are on treatment,
that are virally suppressed.
So you can see the bars in
terms of the percent positive,
the percent on treatment,
and then those that are virally suppressed
in red, blue and gray respectively.
What's important also
to note on the slide,
is the percentage in orange,
which is the community viral suppression.
It's absolutely incredible
when you look particularly
at the left side of this graph here,
to see Botswana at 93, 98, 98,
with 89% community viral suppression,
Malawi, a very resource limited country,
at 88, 98, 97% with 84% viral suppression
at the community level.
Just extraordinary how
far countries have come
together with communities
as a result of Americans
leadership and generosity
in really working on this fight together.
Next slide.
It's important also to note
that even in the midst of COVID-19,
that PEPFAR has continued
to not only maintain
the number of people that
we have on treatment,
but we've continued to grow
the number of people that
we have on treatment,
despite the peaks in
COVID-19 transmission.
So on this slide across,
in color, you can see the number
of waves of COVID 19 cases
per million people
in a select number of
countries around the globe.
And in red, you can see
the number of individuals
that have continued and
grown on life saving ART.
Next slide.
I also wanted to show here
that we have had challenges
as a result of COVID-19.
These data show our circumcision
performance over time,
over a few year period.
You can see where COVID in
quarter three of fiscal year 20
really impacted the program,
where the services dropped dramatically.
This was intentional, we had made sure,
that we were doing
everything that we could,
at the height of COVID-19,
to really protect the
people that we were serving
to keep them out of the way of COVID,
of infection from COVID-19.
What we are seeing over time, however,
is that with adaptation to the program,
we've been able to rebound
and stabilize the program
over the quarters.
And this is quarter three data,
but shows that 70% achievement
toward our annual target,
again, this is complementary
to where we were
in previous fiscal year.
So again, we've been able to rebound
and this is really
because of incredible work
that has happened at the country level
by extraordinary people and partners
that we're working with,
and real time adaptation to the program.
Next slide.
And here just gives you a sense
of some of the prevention services
and pre-exposure prophylaxis
for adolescent girls and young women.
Similarly, you can see a dip
in our prevention services
for adolescent girls and young women
on the left side of the
graph, but a stark increase,
after we started to
really adapt the program
and use different modalities
to implement prevention activities.
And with pre-exposure prophylaxis here,
you see sort of a stabilization,
through COVID-19 when
the impact really came,
but the important thing here,
is a real steep incline through COVID.
This shows us some of the preferences
that the people we serve have,
and so PrEP is something
that we're really actively
trying to scale up
not just for adolescent
girls and young women,
but all populations.
Next slide.
Over the while,
while we have been a
categorical HIV focused program,
and we've been working to
sustain through COVID-19,
sustain those HIV gains, we
have been pivoting and adapting
to really respond in the wake of COVID-19.
We often talk about the PEPFAR platform.
And what does that mean?
Well, what we've learned over time,
is that all of the effort
that we've been able to do
in partnership with countries,
communities and partners,
over the years on HIV services
and delivering HIV services,
has effectively created
a care delivery platform
that has, yes been instrumental to HIV,
but has also recently been instrumental
to responding to COVID-19.
We have thousands of US government teams,
from the various agencies,
CDC, USA, Peace Corps,
the Department of
Defense, all of the very,
NIH, all the various
health and human services,
operating divisions and others.
We have local, strong
local implementing partners
and trusted relationships
with partner governments,
all in 55 countries around the globe.
These relationships, these
people, these partners,
together with the
incredible health system,
infrastructure investments
that we have made
over the course of PEPFAR's life,
which is really, been
expressed as over $15 billion,
but tangibly resulted in
over 3000 laboratories
just on the continent of Africa,
that have been established and networked,
including reference laboratories.
Over 70,000 healthcare facilities
in which we work with
direct access to clients
as well as granular data
at all of these facilities.
Nearly 300,000 healthcare workers
that we have trained on HIV, doctors,
nurses, community health workers,
epidemiologist, laboratorians, etc,
in a robust commodity supply
chain that is in place.
It is this system, this platform,
that has been critical
to respond to COVID-19.
Since COVID really hit
the globe in early 2020,
we've been adapting our program
and leveraging this platform
to support COVID-19 screening,
diagnostics, infection
prevention and control,
demand generation for vaccination,
as well as administration
of vaccines themselves.
I think Secretary Blinken said it best,
when he was recently in
Africa a couple of weeks ago,
where he said, "PEPFAR has
saved millions of lives,
"brought the world to the edge
"of the first AIDS free generation
"and transformed public
health infrastructure,
"where the investments we made
years ago in labs and clinics
"formed the backbone of this
nation's COVID response."
And he was specifically
talking about Nigeria,
but this is true across the board.
Next slide.
And the President himself,
yesterday during the World AIDS
Day ceremony, said it again,
with his words,
"By strengthening countries'
abilities to fight AIDS,
"we've also improved
our collective ability
"to fight other diseases."
And we couldn't agree more.
Next slide.
So as I noted, since early March,
I would say or late February 2020,
we have been adapting the PEPFAR program
and providing technical
guidance on how we can lean in,
to leverage the PEPFAR
supported health systems
and infrastructure, and as I noted,
to do everything from COVID-19
screening and diagnostics,
and now all the way to vaccination.
Next slide.
One of the things that
we did at the outset,
when COVID-19 first hit was,
was really make sure we
can protect the HIV gains.
We did a number of things
to ensure that we were focused
on person-centered care
to protect the populations
most at risk for poor COVID-19
infection outcomes as well.
So things that we
implemented with urgency was,
making sure that people on treatment had,
we had absolute connection with them,
tracking methodology platforms in place
so that we can ensure
that their treatment was uninterrupted.
We rolled out multi-month
dispensing in a matter of weeks,
we have been,
this is something that we have been at
with country governments for years,
but it wasn't until COVID-19,
that country governments realized
the importance to move quickly,
to ensure three and six months
of drugs for stable clients.
This was a way to decompress facilities,
and also make sure
that we were reducing the
potential exposure of COVID-19
to people living with HIV.
We decentralized drug delivery,
we went closest to home,
closest to the communities
where the people we serve are.
We used virtual platforms,
telemedicine and other ways,
to communicate with
beneficiaries of our programs.
A lot of the prevention programming
that we had traditionally done
in-person, in group settings
was not possible during COVID-19.
And so we were able to adapt
and institute virtual platforms quickly.
And I can't say enough about
empowering communities,
and how important communities
and local partners have been
in this fight but
particularly through COVID-19.
Community led monitoring
to ensure quality services
and leveraging community health workers
has been absolutely critical.
Next slide.
This is just an example,
wanted to show some data
of the rapid increase
in the percentage of
people living with HIV,
that were on ART comparing
fiscal year 20 quarter one data,
to fiscal year 21 quarter three data.
And these data reflect,
though the multi-month
dispensing that I noted earlier,
you can see when you look at
the left side of the graph
compared to the right side of the graph,
the increase in three to six months
of drugs for stable clients.
So again, country by country,
you can see a real increase in shift from,
toward, I should say,
more months of drugs.
And this has been a saving
grace in the wake of COVID-19.
Next slide.
We've been so grateful that
the Congress and this President
appropriated additional resources
specifically for us to
respond to COVID-19.
We received $250 million
to prevent and mitigate COVID-19 impacts
on PEPFAR programs and beneficiaries.
And I guess I should start by saying,
I didn't say this earlier,
PEPFAR is a tremendous effort
implemented in 55 countries,
but over the past 18 years,
reflects $100 billion of
American taxpayer dollars
in this enormous global HIV response.
But that was focused on HIV specifically,
receiving $250 million
to really focus in on utilizing the system
and the platform we have in place
to really respond to
COVID-19 has been critical.
So we were pleased
to be able to program
these resources quickly,
so that we could continue
to utilize the platform
to help respond specifically to COVID-19.
Next slide.
I wanted to provide a
couple of country examples,
and these are hot off the
press as of 7 a.m this morning,
when we had a global call home
with all of the 55 countries.
To really talk about how
we can and should continue
to lean in and utilize the
PEPFAR supported platform
to help in COVID
vaccination in particular,
particularly with the recent variant
and the need for us to
really mobilize quickly.
This is an example from South Africa,
with their ongoing COVID-19
vaccination support.
And these are just examples
of ways that we are bringing
both of these efforts together,
the HIV response and the COVID-19 response
to be nimble and to be impactful
as COVID-19 continues to
rage on the continent.
So we're doing everything here
from supporting the healthcare workforce,
that is doing everything
from data capturing
to vaccination in arms, as I said earlier,
to procuring equipment
and protective equipment,
vaccine consumables, freezers,
ways to support vaccine delivery,
transport, logistic support.
Data systems are absolutely critical,
including supporting the
national department of health
and working together.
So again, these are ways
that we are bringing
these efforts together.
On the next slide.
And here's an example from Zambia,
really important and critical work,
that they've been able to do,
focusing in on PEPFAR
supported facilities where,
that are focused for
delivering antiretrovirals
to people living with HIV.
So a real intentional focus
on vaccinating people living with HIV
in existing ART clinics.
And so what they have seen
in a matter of weeks really,
is a focused effort in these ART clinics,
in high burden areas in Lusaka.
In a week we're able to
vaccinate 1000 people
living with HIV, again,
and that mushroomed where other facilities
across now over 500 facilities,
across all 10 provinces in Zambia
are rolling out this program.
Really pushing COVID-19 vaccination
for people living with HIV
as well as family members and
others that accompany them.
The ministry of health was
so thrilled about this,
that they issued a circular,
which is, there's a picture
here in late August,
they issued a circular expanding
this policy and this effort
across all 10 provinces.
So we're really excited about this,
and looking forward to what
might be able to be achieved
by bringing these efforts together.
Next slide.
And again, they used the opportunity
of World AIDS Day yesterday,
to really bring together a
COVID-19 vaccination surge
with World AIDS Day activities.
So bringing a really high level push
from the government of Zambia,
together with the US government
to see what might be possible
by the end of this fiscal year,
oh sorry, by the end
of this calendar year,
by bringing a real push
for COVID-19 vaccination.
Next slide.
There are of course
challenges and opportunities
to sustaining epidemic control of HIV.
And as I noted, and showed in
the population based surveys,
there are countries that are getting,
that new infections are
continuing to drive down
and all cause mortality is
being driven down as well.
Countries are beginning to
control their epidemics.
But there are challenges,
including inequities
that continue to persist
among adolescent girls and young women,
key populations and children.
And these are areas where we
are trying to double down.
COVID-19, of course continues to persist,
and this is something
that we need to continue to
proactively get ahead of,
to ensure that we're not just
protecting the gains in HIV,
but continuing to advance
and accelerate those gains
in the midst of COVID-19.
And there are real opportunities
to tackle some of these inequities
by working differently across sectors,
by really bringing a refreshed perspective
to how we're disaggregating data
across younger and more specific
populations, for example,
to drive where our investments go.
And then again, utilizing the
platform in different ways
to help respond for the future.
Next slide.
There are some elements about,
what a sustained response
to epidemic control of HIV
might look like.
And it really has to do with
equitable health services
and solutions across the board.
But there are elements
that include a whole of domestic approach,
between the government's,
the partner governments and communities,
enabling policy and
programmatic environments
that remain barriers to services,
but that having these in
place are absolutely critical.
Sufficient functional capacity
to maintain these programs
and these services,
financial sustainability
is essential as well,
domestic resource mobilization.
And then integrating HIV services
into the broader public and
private care delivery systems,
to really ensure
that when we have a country
at epidemic control of HIV,
that we are really
ensuring that that control,
which is a very dynamic
place remains in control.
And so ensuring that a
robust public health response
to monitor and track
existing and emerging threats
becomes even more critical,
as does quality assurance.
Next slide.
Just a couple of slides on finances.
HIV investments by Funder.
This slide shows by country on
the right side of the graph,
the percent contribution from PEPFAR,
the US government in
blue, the Global Fund,
which the US is a big contributor to,
and then partner governments in gray.
And we continue to work seamlessly
across partner governments,
the Global Fund and with the US government
to make sure that our
investments and services
complement one another.
Next slide.
But we continue to be
concerned because of COVID-19.
When we look at the projected
gross domestic product growth
versus HIV prevalence rate
as seen on this graph,
you can see economic problems
from COVID across the board,
but are pervasive and worse
in countries with high HIV prevalence
as noted in the red dots
on the right side of the graph here.
Next slide.
One approach that we've been utilizing,
is sustaining delivery of HIV services
through local and community partners.
This has been an approach
to sustainability
that we have been trying to employ
for a number of years now.
And we're seeing significant gains
and movement in the right direction here,
where we're really working to make sure
that funding is going directly
to local and community
partners themselves,
as you can see in the
graph across the country.
Some countries have over
80% of their funding
going to local partners.
And it's not just the funding,
it's ensuring that the local capacity
and capabilities of these partners exist
to implement services in
the respective countries.
Next slide, please.
Just a couple of final slides here,
just to note that we're
really bringing an equity lens
to the effort to complement
our work on accountability,
transparency and impact,
to really make sure
we're closing those gaps
that I noted earlier.
And on the next slide.
And I'll stop here, which is,
we've been working with many of you
and others across the globe,
to develop a PEPFAR strategy
for the next five years,
to help guide our efforts moving forward.
And these really relate to
accomplishing the mission,
finishing what we started,
building enduring capabilities,
as I noted earlier, how
critical health systems,
enabling environments
and local partners are,
and finally building
lasting collaborations.
Next slide.
And with that, I'll just say thank you,
and turn it back over to you Saad.
- Hi.
So Dean Vermund was,
started the event on our,
hosted event on behalf of Yale
Institute for Global Health,
unfortunately, he is in
transit in Dominican Republic.
So while he is connected,
I will be filling in for him
for the question answer sessions.
And, we'd be happy to
sort of fill questions
from the audience, as well
as, a few other questions,
that we've been thinking about.
So first of all, thank
you for a really nice talk
and a comprehensive overview
of the progress of PEPFAR.
And what are some of the things
PEPFAR has been doing lately.
And those of you who don't
know me, I'm Saad Omer,
I'm the director of Yale
Institute for Global Health.
So, the first question
actually came from our
participants, our audience.
And I think it's very timely
in the context of the overall environment.
Because there was very strong
bipartisan support for PEPFAR,
when it was first launched.
Do you still see that support?
- Thanks so much Saad.
I have to say, you're right,
when PEPFAR was first launched,
there was incredible bipartisan support,
across the US government with
President George W. Bush,
who was extraordinary
in launching such an incredible effort,
but also across the Congress,
from Republicans to Democrats.
You know, there's something
magnificent about the HIV fight,
it brings all walks of life together.
And what we've seen over the
years in the past 18 years,
and what I noted in my
presentation, is that,
every year since, every
administration since
and every change of Congress since,
they have equally come in and brought,
stood on the other's shoulders,
and really continued to bring
the highest level of congressional
and presidential bipartisan leadership.
And as I noted, most recently
with President Biden,
it wasn't just with World AIDS Day,
where the enormous support and leadership
of the global response was displayed.
Since day one of this administration,
President Biden and the administration
has really put their arm,
have put their arms around this
issue supporting all of us,
and the effort and the fight,
in every way that we have come together
in the multilateral space.
There was the UN high
level meeting this summer,
that happens every five years,
where the administration
showed full support,
but all the way to the
way the budget looks,
to the way, again, the
political leadership as well.
So they've also recently
announced, that the US will host
the next replenishment of the Global Fund,
to really make sure that we are advancing
our efforts for HIV, TB, and
malaria around the globe,
through our multilateral efforts as well.
So the bipartisan support
has been critical,
it's been maintained and
grown over the years,
and we're incredibly grateful for that.
- That's wonderful.
So the second question comes
actually from Dean Vermund.
And he raised an interesting point,
that it's obviously really good to see
that PEPFAR has aided in
the COVID-19 response,
especially the in-country infrastructure,
has been repurposed, utilized,
and by the way not for the first time
for a major public health emergency.
Can you comment on other
expansion of mission
as with the non communicable diseases,
and people have sort of
strong opinions on that,
but one is that, it's a no brainer,
that you have built that infrastructure,
and there's this new,
not new, but this emerging
and important issue
of non communicable disease.
But on the other hand,
there's this instinct a few people have,
is to preserve the capacity
for a purpose that it was created.
So we'd love to hear your
thoughts about expansion to NCDs.
- Yeah, no, thank you for
that important question.
And, as we as,
you're right, in that the PEPFAR platform
hasn't only been utilized for COVID-19,
there have been so many
ways over the years,
whether it's other
infectious, areas like Ebola,
or when H1N1, SARS, MERS,
so many other areas,
but we've also been utilizing
the platform to respond to TB,
to respond to cervical cancer.
And so those are examples
of how we've expanded
to help really move
in the direction of non
communicable diseases.
I think the question is a really good one.
Because there is a very delicate
dance that we have to do,
in order to make sure
that we don't dilute our efforts in HIV.
While we do what we know
is the smart thing to do,
which is to utilize capacity
that exists to help respond.
And so that's why we've been
very deliberate and careful
about how we've been responding
to COVID-19, for example,
tying it to looking at
the data and making sure
that we are doing everything
to preserve the HIV gains,
while we've been able to
expand as we've needed to.
I think we would be,
look, we haven't finished the fight yet.
And that's why I mentioned,
there are gaps that persist,
and we've gotta close those gaps for HIV.
But we've gotta,
we can't also ignore the fact that,
there is this incredible
system that exists,
and whether we like it or not,
countries realize and see
the power of the systems
and capabilities that are in place,
and see the need to be able
to bring synergy together.
So my thought is, we
need all ships to rise,
we need to utilize that
platform that exists,
because starting from
scratch doesn't make sense.
But we've gotta be able to do it
in a very careful and considerate way,
so that the outcomes
that we've been able to
achieve together on HIV,
don't backslide.
- Yeah, and we got a sort
of a related question,
saying that, and obviously,
we definitely don't want
to lose the progress
that we have all made so far,
and diversify the HIV AIDS funding sources
to address the COVID-19 pandemic.
So, as someone who sort
of has run this kind of,
a program of this magnitude,
do you think there's a need
for a new fund or some sort of,
another entity or a resource for COVID-19
and future pandemics.
Because we don't have to
have a pie of a fixed size,
we can increase the
size of the pie itself,
public health is extremely cost efficient,
we get really high returns on investment.
But would you think there is a value
on a separate fund for
pandemics or COVID-19,
or something of that sort?
- So, the global health architecture
and what the future looks like,
is a hot topic of conversation,
as I'm sure you're very well
aware of and immersed in.
And, I think,
and part of the reason I showed
what was possible with $250 million
of the American Rescue Plan funds,
was that with a relatively
small amount of money,
$250 million in our $6
billion a year program,
how much we've been able to do,
because we have systems and capacity
and infrastructure in place.
So, I guess, setting up a fund,
specifically for pandemic
preparedness and response,
there's certainly a different skills,
there's a broader skill set
that needs to be brought to bear
that is not solely in the
HIV sphere, but the time,
the time that might be involved
to do something like that,
when we should be,
when we're in the midst of
two pandemics right now,
HIV and COVID-19, and being
able to respond quickly,
that's only possible with infrastructure
that is on the ground and
capacity on the ground right now
to mobilize quickly.
And so, I guess that's
the long way of saying,
I think a fund,
I think a separate fund,
again, we'll see where the conversation
of global health architecture falls,
but there's definitely
something to be said,
for building on investments
that have already been made,
because that's a fast
efficient way to work.
- Yeah, though I think,
and, of course, we'll have to think about,
the horizontal versus
vertical nature of programs.
You know, obviously, there
are trade offs there,
on both sides, or sort
of the diagonal nature
of some of these programs
that are sort of hybrid
between vertical and horizontal programs.
So do you think,
now is the time for a PEPFAR
level effort specifically,
so not necessarily PEPFAR,
but a vaccine distribution
effort that is of that scope?
So some of us called for
it like in March of 2020.
So, yes, we have discussed
that there is this,
the issues of a separate fund,
but it's more long term, etc.
But more immediately, do we
need something of that magnitude
for this problem that we have right now
where we need an end to end solution?
- Yeah, no, thank you for that question.
It's such an important one.
And, again, in the same
way that President Biden
has really expressed tremendous support
of the global HIV response,
we were so pleased,
and I hope many of you participated in
or have been tracking the
global summit on COVID-19
that occurred around the UN
General Assembly in the fall.
Where the President, really
tried to mobilize the world,
to step up on vaccination
across the globe,
putting bold targets out there of 70%,
trying to get the coverage
rate to 70% across countries
and what that could look
like and how we as a globe,
not just the United
States but we as a globe
need to sort of collectively
move in this way.
So, and we've since had
some follow up ministerials
to really try and urge,
the vaccine delivery and administration.
The US has been donating,
hundreds of millions of vaccine,
one of the concerns that we have,
and I'm just giving an example
from the African context is,
there's a lot of supply,
actually, right now,
in many of the countries.
One of the many concerns
is much of what we face
here as well, hesitancy,
actually getting vaccination
administered in a timely way.
We're seeing some waste
of some of the vaccines.
So these are questions that
are also being considered.
- So, look, you have a
particular strength as a leader,
because your own background
includes a lot of work
in the field itself.
And I hope we sort of
nurtured some of those values
and attitudes here at Yale, at
an early part in your career.
But what do you think,
how has that informed
your leadership style
as you have sort of risen to
sort of leadership positions
within the program itself?
And is there anything,
any insight that you can
share with our students
from that perspective?
Someone from the field,
someone who has gotten
their hands dirty that,
someone who hasn't been
dropped into an agency,
as an appointee with
a lot of other assets,
but not necessarily field experience,
but you have direct field experience.
Any insights?
- Well, I so appreciate that question.
And speaking directly
to the students at Yale.
So, on a personal level,
let me just tell you a
little bit about why,
the number one why I chose Yale,
and why Yale and the approach,
the comprehensive approach
of the public health program,
the global health program in particular,
was so instrumental in
forming me in my career,
in my service,
that I've since been
doing 20 plus years since.
What is extraordinary,
what was extraordinary
then 20 plus years ago,
when I was a student there,
as a Master's student,
and what drew me in,
and what I know is still
consistent at Yale,
is the comprehensive
multi sectoral approach
of the global health effort.
When I first started it, it was brand new,
it was a newer field, a
newer part of the program.
But what I loved about it was,
how we at the time,
had professors and opportunities
from the medical school,
from the business school, from the,
there was a multi-sectoral approach
that was absolutely critical.
One of the experiences that
really changed my world,
was what many, I don't know
if this is still part of
the curriculum at Yale,
but the summer between
first and second year
of the master's program,
when there was some sort
of internship type work,
that's when I went to
UNICEF to start that,
to do my internship.
And that turned into a love of this work,
that then turned into going to the field,
that then turned into time in countries.
And that began my love for this work,
and for the service,
that I've done as a career public servant.
As you noted, I'm not a political,
I have been in the government
and experienced some of the real struggles
and issues that people face,
in communities, all around the globe,
and to be a part of something,
no matter how big or small,
something that is really making
an impact on their lives,
is the greatest honor of my lifetime.
And so it's just, it really
did start with that approach
that Yale instilled in me,
of service, of experiencing the field,
and translating science and research
into real public health impact, so.
Yeah.
- So that's wonderful to hear,
and you'll be happy to know,
that the Yale Institute for Global Health
has actually formalized
a global health leadership
fellows program,
that is open to any
trainee and student at Yale
from undergrad to actual
postdocs research and clinical,
and everyone in between
including graduate students, etc,
that has a formal pre-departure component,
then we place them in global
health agencies like UNICEF,
as you did that, save the
children and many others.
And then we will expand to
ministries of health as well.
This is in addition to
field placement program,
this has a specific focus
on leadership and service,
particularly public service.
And so that program has expanded
and it's good to know that,
these kinds of investments pay off,
so this particular program
is new and expanded,
but the earlier efforts have,
I think, I can say confidently,
has had a high return on investment.
And so, in terms of, going back to,
a little bit of focus on
partnerships that you mentioned,
specifically, thinking about
how faith-based organizations
can be leveraged to help with HIV AIDS,
stigma, prevention and care.
And what are the new (muffled speaking)
'cause I know that PEPFAR
has, from the beginning,
collaborated with
faith-based organizations,
but what are the new directions
in that kind of partnerships?
And what are some of the lessons?
Because look, other sectors,
other entities will have to partner
with faith-based entities
and organizations,
from the grassroots to the global level,
and some lessons from PEPFAR
would be very, sort of,
would be very useful for
those sectors as well.
- Yeah, I know, it's such
an important question,
and an important sector that
is critical to the response.
You know, I mentioned
earlier in my remarks
that there's something extraordinary
about the HIV fight and that
it brings so much diversity,
so many sectors together.
Everything from it, and
part of part of that,
is the bipartisan support from Congress,
just as many Republicans as
Democrats love this program.
We have the most
conservative religious groups
that have critical roles to play
in the response, as the most liberal,
NGOs or LGBTQI plus organizations,
our advocacy groups are so broad.
So, again, there's something beautiful,
about the global HIV fight
that has brought so many people together.
Faith-based organizations,
as you noted, Saad,
faith-based organizations
have been critical to this
response from the very outset.
And I talked a little bit
about local community organizations,
and I include faith-based organizations
in that broader subset.
Faith-based groups have been
there in these countries
before we were there.
They have access to people in
ways that we absolutely need,
to talk about some very sensitive issues
like stigma and discrimination,
today, I mentioned, we were on,
with all of the country offices,
and we were talking specifically about
involving faith-based organizations
in COVID vaccination for
people living with HIV,
because there's a real hesitancy
among pregnant women living with HIV,
and their hesitancy about COVID vaccine
and the impact that it
might have on their child.
And so, the conversation was around,
well, how do we involve
faith-based organizations
that are trusted institutions
in many of these countries,
and that have influence
in so many different ways.
So again, I think they have played,
they continue to play,
and they will always be
needed in the response.
- Wonderful.
And the last question is,
many, and I think I know
who asked this question,
from our audience,
someone with a sort of a
significant student role.
The question is, many in
our audience are students
that aspire to work in global health.
What is your advice to these students,
as they consider what to do after Yale?
I know you have alluded
to some of that stuff,
but I think, we'd love
to end on that note.
- So what to do after Yale?
Well, the good news is,
is you're getting a really
incredible experience
while you're at Yale.
And I would encourage you
to seize all of these opportunities,
including that new,
or the fellowship that
you were describing Saad,
the new, the way you've institutionalized
that field experience, because
that's really exciting.
You know, I would encourage
you to be open and flexible.
It's amazing how, oftentimes,
as I reflect back now,
oftentimes, there's never a direct route
to where you're headed, when
it comes to your career.
But there are experiences that
if you're open to seizing,
it could move you in a way that
really compels you to focus.
And that's what happened for me,
there was a incredible opportunity,
it was a fellowship at CDC,
that was specifically focused on,
integrating services across the,
and this was domestic,
but across the education
and health sectors.
And that intrigued me,
because of a lot of the work
that we were doing in
the global health space
of bringing different sectors together,
and that's one of the
things I learned at UNICEF
when I did my internship there.
And that intrigued me.
And so I applied and got that fellowship,
and that set me on a course,
that in terms of
integrating across sectors
and integrating services for adolescents,
and that has been evolved.
And, again, I just,
being flexible and focused on the mission
and on service that you're
compelled by, and inspired by,
I think really helps move forward.
But also reach out to
people that you know,
that are in various places, as well,
because we are always
looking for good people
to join our teams.
- Wonderful.
Thank you.
And as you alluded to that, PEPFAR,
and I think if I can say so,
PEPFAR reflects the best of America.
Bipartisan, with empathy,
with adequate resources,
bringing in good, solid
technical expertise,
but at the end of the day,
partnering with communities and countries,
and working as true partners,
rather than parachuting in solutions,
and having long-term commitment.
So I hope, PEPFAR remains that example,
but doesn't remain the isolated,
one of the, no, I wouldn't say rare,
but one of the few examples
of this country making solid
investments in global health,
that results in this win win situation.
And I'm sure it's been a
privilege for you as well I hope,
that to lead this incredible
program in the recent past.
So thanks for coming.
And thanks for your words,
and engaging us in this conversation.
- Thank you so much.
And thank you for the opportunity.
And it really has been a
privilege of a lifetime,
to be a part of something
that has really been a
movement around the globe.
So I am just so grateful
to have been with you today
and shared how some of
my roots there from Yale
have helped contribute to who I am today
and the service that I've
been so privileged to provide
on behalf of the American people.
So thank you very much.
- Yeah, thank you, thanks for coming,
and thank you for all of
you who joined us today.
We look forward to seeing
you at the next event,
of YIGH's conversations
series in early 2022.
We have a pretty exciting
program brewing for you,
and happy holidays.
- Thank you.